i think people in prison got nothing but
time on our hands
so this is not a rushed product hi my
name is mario and i'm an ex-felon
greetings my name is drew langley i'm
the general manager owner of
cali restaurant los angeles today i'll
be teaching a professional
somebody how to make wine a perfectly
present you ready to do this
[Music]
okay today group we're gonna be making
prison wine that's what we call
pruno today i'll be showing you how to
make that first we're going to start
get your bucket you're going to open
these both bags and double them up and
then we align
the plastic batter here because we're
going to pressure proof inside got it
preferably using a new socket of course
but this side is what we use to strain
our food we're going to take the apple
juice
we're going to put the apple inside the
sock and the palm your hand
against the wood what's the most common
fruit that you have access to when
you're doing that
apples then we're going to grab
a grapefruit depending on what you had
in prison you're allowed to have
grapefruit we're going to tell this
here in florida i think people in prison
got nothing but time on our hands
so this is not a rushed product then
we're going to do some oranges i want to
make sure
that we use the same type of fruit that
allowed in prison to make
reservoirs so how do you conceal it um
well
when you do it after after you cooking
it it takes the process of about
seven to ten days and
the the correction officers search sales
every day
so to sell these searches or so you put
it in after they finish searching got it
because they're going to rotate it yeah
so it's like playing hot potato
why do you call it fruno pruno is a
prison slang term just like a weapon is
a shank
how much does fruity go for uh probably
five out of the cup
i bet it would turn out different if you
use an old sock
oh yes it would yeah it probably would
import apple juice that we saved in a
container like this
pour it in you get food cocktail once a
week take that dump that in there right
there
a cup of hot water yeah so that hot
water will break down the sugars and
make it easier for the yeasts
to break into oh so that's what it is i
don't know yeah we have sugar packs
right here you get these in your package
you get a
yearly package that your family can send
you uh-huh for the next the last thing
we do
we have a kicker in a separate bag like
this
and it would be the spoiled rotten fruit
food
cocktail that you saved okay we want to
do that with a sock out the way
but we don't want to have a sock in our
pooch
so what we're doing now tie the bag
once you heat this up and the sugar
what's it what it started doing it start
to blow up yeah and when it starts to
blow up that's how i know it's cooking
that's how i know you get this once it
blew up you will untie this and you call
it burping
it will be blew up and you will burp it
down like this
and then all the air out and you can
smell the pruning through the bag and
noise right that's part of the chemical
reaction that happens with the
fermentation so the yeast eats the sugar
and it gets up three
by products those three byproducts are
going to be alcohol
but carbon dioxide which fills up the
bag oh
and the third byproduct is heat warms up
yes so there it is this cup you're gonna
pour into here
and we're gonna drink
it's always bitter
[Music]
but you imagine that being cut for three
or four more days
yeah with the thing but and then that's
what you get pronoun and it really gives
you a buzz if you you know you're the
expert
sure i'm mad at drinking some more water
well you see if we can i'd like to do an
experiment real quick yeah i'll get a
wine glass
okay cool so you take your pruning and
put it in the wine glass all right
all right okay so what you first i'm
going to do you're going to look at the
clarity
of this so this is definitely unfind
unfiltered if you wanted a more pure
product
i'd run it through the sock a couple
more times of course yeah
cheers cheers
[Music]
y'all trying to give me faith here we go